on a tout à fait dans notre vie que ce
soit homme ou femme et au final quand je
rentre chez moi et que les huit mois
plus tard on m'envoie la vidéo en me
disant petit souvenir de nous
cinquante casse a dit ok cool pourquoi
donc ça veut dire ce petit souvenir de
nous ils envoyaient vous les 50000 euros
pour ne pas diffuser la vidéo c'est
exactement ça a commencé de l'aca a
commencé à deux on fait comment moi que
tu sais je galère dans ma vie dit
et puis voilà et je pense que ta famille
sera pas contente en fait alors ses
marques platanes influenceurs qui vous a
contacté marque était de me voir
facetime voilà qui vous a contacté un
soir il ya environ six mois pour vous
prévenir qu'un homme lui avait parlé de
ces vidéos c'est ça ouais en fait moi
c'est le soir où il ça à la veille de
balance les vidéos geismar qui m'appelle
qui me renvoie premièrement une capture
d'écran ou là je vois la vidéo qui
supprime directement donc là on peut se
dire que vraiment ils montée
d'adrénaline arrive je me dis qu'est-ce
que je vais faire comme moi je vais
faire comme moi je la touche à mes
parents et là ce moment-là je me dis bah
c'est quoi pose-toi il m'a dit on se
revoit demain pour en parler qu'ils
allaient avoir la personne au téléphone
et je me suis dit mais en fait non j'ai
pas envie de passer au téléphone avec
untel untel est en fait c'est pas les
enchères mon corps n'est pas les
enchères cette vidéo n'est pas les
enchères en fait est arrivé à un moment
donné je me suis posée j'ai contacté
mais de grand frère jared j'écoute il
s'est passé ça ça ça à telle période
j'ai appelé ma mère judy écoute ya un
truc qui va sortir c'est moi qui va le
faire parce qu'en fait il y en a assez
arrivé à un moment donné parce que vous
en aviez marre du chantage ou a dit je
fais sortir moi même la vidéo terminée
exactement c'est voilà maintenant tu
veux me faire peur avec ça bahia
personnes qui me fait peur et je lai
balance moi même en fait ouais c'est ça
oui valley robinet non mais il ya un
phénomène qui s'appelle le revenge porn
dont on entend de plus en plus parler il
faut dire à toutes les jeunes filles qui
nous regardent ce soir et tous les
jeunes garçons parce que ça peut aussi
arriver à des garçons
1 ne cédez pas mais d'abord surtout ne
faites pas ne fait pas ses fameuses
vidéos puisque en souriant sarhadi tout
le monde l'a fait tout le monde le fait
d'avoir été de banaliser ce truc là et
justement ça peut être extrêmement
dangereux ça va aujourd'hui c'est un
phénomène qui revient qui peut revenir
en boomerang à des gamines de 12 13 14
ans à qui on demande d'enlever le
t-shirt à qui on demande de se montrer
en petite culotte et c'est sa pelouse et
la ville hors
normes et conventions histoire ça au
départ quand marc vous appelle et vous
avez dit non vous avez réussi à
convaincre l'homme qui vous avez filmé
de ne pas diffuser ces vidéos en fait
avant que marc ment pas cette personne
là était venu direct demant à moi
essayer de me soutirer de l'argent pour
sortir ces vidéos ça n'a pas marché
parce que je lui ai dit concrètement je
vais pas te mentir c'est pas du tout en
fait tu vas me détruire on va dire
clairement ça va me détruire ma famille
y aura la honte je lui dit mais tu sais
quoi je suis en fait c'est pas la
première fois que ça se passe et qu'en
fait une fois de plus une fois de plus
une fois de plus un moment donné bah je
vais faire des choses vis-à-vis de moi
ou jean ou en fait j'ai honte de moi
alors que je devrais pas oui j'ai parlé
du suicide je vais parler de suicide je
lui ai dit tu sais que ça peut aller
très loin dans ses histoires ça peut me
déprime et ça peut aller vraiment très
long et de la balle à personne elle un
peu compris elle s'est calmée pendant
quelques mois et je lui dis surtout que
un moment vous avez et à lui donner les
50000 euros pas du tout j'avais pas du
tout je vais et je vais pas vous mentir
je préfère me mettre dans le mal moi que
donner quelque chose à quelqu'un parce
qu'en vrai
qu'elle mérite en fait ça veut dire
qu'elle aura gagné tout ce que en fait
tout ce qu'elle est a voulu alors à
gagner je donne 50 mais le roi elle
alors voilà vidéo à quelqu'un d'autre
c'est comment je dis personne derrière
nom paraît que vous avez pensé au pire à
ce moment là ouais ouais vraiment mais
vraiment vous êtes dit ma vie est foutue
vraiment c'est mais c'est ma vie est
foutue parce que ces outils on va pas se
mentir et maintenant moi je suis on va
pas turbo on va parler français je suis
une rebuse chez nous c'est un truc de
ouf en vrai de vrai c'est un truc de ouf
et en fait quand tu ce qui s'est passé
ça j'ai des grands frères je suis la
petite dernière chez la fille je me suis
dit ok d'accord peut-être c'est moi
camardes et et tu peux penser il ya
plusieurs personnes qui pensent comme
vous et qui dit mais pourquoi s'est
laissé filmer mais en fait quoi alors je
vais très très clairs j'aimerais vous
dis je sais pas vous là c'est pas vous
qui devait avoir honte en moi et vous
vous êtes fait filmer et peut importer
ses pas et c'est pas grave si on décide
de le faire on décide de le faire celui
qui doit avoir honte c'est celui qui
ensuite décident d'exploiter ces vidéos
une fois que la relation est terminée
vraiment soyons très très clairs là
dessus non je préviens simplement des
petites jeunes filles de faire attention
parce que voilà la vidéo de son corps
c'est toujours non wivine parallèlement
à cette diffusion courageux de la vidéo
est ce que vous avez donc vous avez
diffusé la vidéo avec quel courage et
vos parents vos confrères bas au final
au début c'était réticence à me disait
de ne pas mettre la vidéo et que si
elles sortaient de de ne pas donner
l'heure à cette personne ne pas relever
sur les réseaux mais en fait j'ai dit
que non et le lendemain quand je les
fais pas ma mère a été contente manoir a
été content parce qu'un madiot
aujourd'hui tu parles pas que pour toi
mj tu parles avec avec des millions de
filles parce qu'il ya des gens
ralentissent en fait il ya des gens dans
leur tête ils se rendent pas compte des
aides qui a derrière ça veut dire que
moi encore ça va j'ai une famille cool
mais si tu as une conne famille
complètement chtarbé qui rentre chez toi
qui te met des coups qui te ramène à
l'hôpital on fait comment sita à 6,6 à
ce moment là qu avec un mari qui est
complètement impulsif qui frappe sa
femme et qui voient ça sur les réseaux
c'est comment en fait les gens ne
connaissent pas la vie des autres et ne
connaissent pas le ressenti de la
personne en elle-même en fait quand ils
font ça donc en fait ma mère a été très
contente même mes frères et on dit
raison de faire ça parce qu'au jour
d'aujourd'hui tu es la seule personne
qui a osé les faire et aujourd'hui tu va
aider beaucoup de personnes à le faire
et à dénoncer cet acte là en fait alors
maître lors alice bouyer vous est
avocate et dont est docteur en droit
quels sont les risques pour ce genre
d'affaires pour le garçon le garçon de
la personne qui fait du chantage mais y
en a plusieurs parce qu'on a tout un
arsenal législatif qui a été prévu alors
déjà en introduction je voudrais quand
même rappeler le courage de saraf réseau
qui a eu le courage de parler parce que
c'est pas fréquent il a pris soin de
brûler votre décision ça bah ouais ouais
et ferrières à milan mais pas celle que
l'on met deux minutes on nettoie
clientèle pour apple non mais elle est
folle ça
y est rappelé qu' on est dans un nouveau
monde aujourd'hui on a les nouvelles
technologies de l'information et la
communication facilite le passage à des
nouvelles formes de délit donc à une
nouvelle forme de cybercriminalité
on a effectivement du revenge bonne on a
des chantages à la sextape comme vous
avez eu on a également des chantages la
webcam on a des comptes chicha qui se
sont créés énormément pendant le
confinement moi j'ai eu énormément de
personnes qui sont venues et tous les
jours qu'ils me contactent pour me dire
voilà j'ai des personnes qui me menace
de diffuser des photos de moi sur les
réseaux sociaux et c'est important d'en
parler parce qu'il est temps que les
victimes réalise qu'elles sont des
victimes parce qu'elles ont sur ce
qu'elles ont honte et madame beinheim la
très bien rappelé
le consistoire de paris
elle l'a très bien rappelé vous l'avez
très bien rappelé et il faut que les
victimes réalisent qu'elles sont des
victimes mais c'est difficile aussi
parce que il ya la honte aussi d'être
affichés devant devant tout le monde
sait aujourd'hui ben moi je trouve ça
très fort ce qu'a fait vrai ça après
bourse que ça permet de dénoncer le
racket et le chantage qui sont des
pratiques dégueulasse et de ça permet de
rassurer plein de jeunes filles et de
jeunes hommes qui ont fait ce genre de
vidéos il n'y a rien de route à ça la
honte elle est du côté de ceux qui les
balances faut rappeler que ces vidéos
elles sont faits dans un cadre privé et
moi ça me fait de la peine quand
j'entends sert à dire j'étais en
dépression j'ai pensé au suicide
franchement moi cette vidéo je les ai
vus comme plein de gens voilà mon sens
alors les gens les gens non mais les
gens voient ça il en marque deux minutes
et passer à autre chose faut arrêter de
penser qu'on porte ça comme un fardeau
toute sa vie bah là tout le monde fait
des vidéos comme ça et c'est pas grave
franchement mais là en fait on le prend
bien parce que c'est moi qui les a
balancés bien sûr c'est le problème ça
veut dire ça aurait été bien c'est
quelqu'un d'autre ça aurait fait le tour
pendant 10 mn pendant une semaine tu es
du doigt on m'aurait traitée de
prostituée mais c'est vrai ma maîtresse
de votre vie vous avez dessiné les
plans chantage ou pas du tout non j'ai
fait ma justice moi-même sur les réseaux
parce que comme comme comme je
l'expliquais souvent alors combien c'est
bien mais aussi un débat justice où il
ya un problème en fait ça veut dire non
il ya un problème pourquoi pourquoi je
vais vous expliquer parce que vous allez
porter plainte mais avant ça on m'a tuer
ma vie life dévoile alors j'en ai
partout non mais
maintenant
oui mais moi en fait pour porter plainte
et chantages et bah moi je suis désolé
mais je suis pas à la hauteur des ses
petites merdes veut pas d'argent je veux
pas
pourquoi il n'était pas une question qui
fait sa présidence
la personne gardée change vous devriez
porter fifi d'accord je suis d'accord et
c'est pour ça et j'encourage les gens à
le faire parce que moi j'ai fait ma
justice moi-même sur les réseaux sociaux
et je peux dire que la personne m'a
contacté et vraiment dans le mal parce
qu'elle veut pas de toute façon je ne
dirai pas son prénom mais en fait l'on
me fait de l'artiste c'est bien mais
pour moi moi personnellement je parle de
moi c'est trop d'eux trop d'il ya trop
de route avant d'arriver au point final
ya trop de souffrances de tant en fait
de mieux mais l'être le rallye selon
david amis de madame benhabib
elle peut porter plainte pour chantage
tout à fait et on a un arsenal
législatif alors qui est quand même très
récent puisqu'il date de 2016 avant 2016
on ne pouvait pas le délit driven stern
n'existait pas il existe depuis 2016
parce qu'on ait une décision de la cour
de cassation qui est qu à scandaliser
tout le monde et on a eu des cadres qui
ont été très graves notamment aux états
unis en italie et aussi en france des
cas de viols des cales de suicide donc
qui ont montré qu'il fallait quand même
faire quelque chose et depuis 2016 le
cadre event borne est sanctionné par le
droit et la peine encourue est de deux
ans d'emprisonnement et de 60000 euros
d'hommes en oxygène circonstances
aggravantes peu importe que la personne
est accepté d'envoyer ou pas ces photos
ou de se faire filmer ou de se faire
enregistrer ou de se faire photographier
à partir du moment où elles sont
diffusées c'est un c'est un délit mais
il ya un deuxième délit derrière qu'est
celui je suis déjà en poche et qui est
important malgré tout d'en parler
puisque le
la personne qui a fait du chantage à
madame fresu madame prévost tout à fait
risque davantage puisqu'il risque cinq
ans d'emprisonnement 34 euros d'amendé
oui
j'avais une question sarah vous dit tout
à l'heure oui chaque jeune fille fait sa
fin s'est passé c'est normal est-ce
qu'il ya d'autres photos ou vidéos qui
seraient susceptibles de sortir sur voie
d'eau concrètement je vais vous dire
sincèrement j'ai eu des zeks après
calcul et il ya des photos il n'ya pas
des photos et c'est même plus maintenant
le problème des ex ou du mec qui va
diffuser la photo aujourd'hui on va
jusqu'à pirater votre téléphone vos
réseaux sociaux je suis désolé je me
suis déjà pris en sous vêtements je me
suis déjà pris à poil c'est pas un choc
mais pour moi même et malheureusement en
fait son pain sont pas chercher la
source en fait trop chaud non mais c'est
quoi le message là qu'aujourd'hui vous
voulez savoir ce que veut le message que
voulait faire passer c'est de dire aux
jeunes filles non c'est pas demain je
sais le faire mais assumez les non c'est
pas le faire et assumé je parle moi des
deux dictateurs voilà je vois
des cas en fait je parle des cas
vraiment où ils sont dans la situation
de chantage les pinceaux d'un dans cette
situation là et ben de ne pas céder et
que c'est pas une honte c'est être une
femme c'est être un être humain c'est
être en couple c'est à avoir des
relations maintenant pour les prochaines
à venir c'est vrai que c'est malheureux
mais on est dans un monde on ne peut pas
avoir confiance en personne vous vous
êtes une page web c'est bon c'est bon
on peut pas avoir confiance en personne
même demain en étant mariée je suis
désolé mais je suis plus confiant et on
avait aujourd'hui la confiance est
perdue il ya que j'ai confiance qu'on
darty
sarah est ce que ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
allez mieux je vous sens enfants méchant
que ça vous a libéré star est clairement
vraiment je vais pas vous mentir le joug
le matin où j'ai balancé ses vidéos
c'est vrai que j'avais une boule au
ventre moi je me suis dit comment ça va
se passer les raisons c'est tous très
bien comment ils peuvent déformer le
truc détourner le truc j'avais une boule
au ventre
donc oui
et donc où ça et de la et de la vraiment
depuis ce jour là vraiment c'est le
lendemain c je suis tranquille mais les
gens sont soulagés ouais vous vous êtes
vous avez un petit fiancé un fiancé non
j'ai une fréquentation et quant à louis
sa part tout d'abord de fréquentation
des containers et à bordeaux oui alors
vous n'avez pas cédé mais est ce que
vous savez si certaines de vos amis
d'autres stars de télé-réalité peuvent
céder appelant le peuple à ses ouailles
en attendant je parlais à pois au nom
des gens bien d'accord je parlais pas au
nom des gens mais je pense que dans ce
milieu là où il y en a beaucoup qui ont
dû céder mais malheureusement ce n'est
pas la solution non mais je croquais
sahraoui c'est un mouvement ouais mais
recule c'est un mouvement très bon état
fréquentation à la 10 kw à 2
bat fréquentation au début quand elle a
vu litres ça c'est dit ok dans quoi je
me lance et en fait au final non est
très contente et au final j'avais déjà
parlé de ces vidéos alors vraiment dire
même pas il ya une semaine avant une
semaine à une semaine avant séparé les
deux ça carrément je me dis tu sais
qu'on m'a déjà fait chanter ah oui et je
te préviens je te préviens si demain il
ya un truc qui sort ou quoi que ce soit
tu es prévenu la friture c'est quoi
eh ben on fréquente toujours
non je dis qu'il ya d'autres stars qui
ont cédé au chantage et qui ont payé
voilà il ya des vidéos qui sont sortis
récemment on va passer des bons mais des
personnes qui ont payé plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'euros en plus
c'était des fausses vidéos des fausse
sextape donc il ne faut surtout pas
céder au chantage alors et par des
plaintes m lors qu'il faut faire dans
ces cas là si ça rit m'a déjà ne pas
céder effectivement et moi je pense
qu'il faut déposer plainte parce qu'il
faut quand même qu'à mon nez ça s'arrête
il faut que le droit disent que voilà
c'est ce sont des peines encourues ya
des peines prononcées qui sont des fois
bien légères malheureusement ça c'est
encore un autre sujet qu'on abordera
peut-être après le sommet
[Rires]
passé déjà et que vous avez tout à fait
raison de ne pas céder parce que
effectivement un chantage après il
faudrait agir le plus vite possible
faire constater par huissier les
éléments d'accord mais c'est vrai que ça
reste quand même assez long et puis
déposé plainte le plus vite possible
alors je vois très souvent des personnes
qui viennent me voir et qui me disent on
a refusé de prendre ma plainte parce
qu'on m'a expliqué que c'est sur les
réseaux c'est sur instagram c'est sur
internet c'est pas la vraie vie et
coupez vos réseaux le problème c'est que
même si vous coupez vos réseaux bas tout
le monde vient vous en parler on vient
vous dire que vous n'auriez pas dû faire
ça on vient vous juger et parfois on
s'isole et parfois on commet
l'irréparable et vous l'avez très bien
expliqué sarah vous avez eu des pensées
noires voici un moment donné c'est parce
qu'elle nous a dit non non ça
aujourd'hui franchement ça va je suis
heureux de te voir comme ça merci non
mais vraiment aller ronfort mme schick
stammtisch donne beaucoup mais c'est
vrai que j'adore ça c'est un amour et
non mais c'est vrai si les gens qui fuit
et voilà et je suis content pour toi
parce que tu es le voilà tu as l'air
sorti d'affaires oui bénin mais j'ai
juste une question madame l'avocate
alors c'est m laura 10 bouvier voilà
maître loeb elle est pour les uns t-il
justement vous dites parfois on quand on
va au commissariat de police et qu'on
refuse de prendre votre votre pratique
on peut insister et dire moi je veux
tout de même malgré tout est obligé
l'officier de police à prendre votre
main alors si on vous dit que non c'est
sur des réseaux et c'est pareil pour les
jeunes gens qui nous regardent
techniquement oui on est objet de points
de votre plainte après c'est vrai que
des fois c'est compliqué vous vous
retrouvez pas toujours mais dans des
situations très difficiles la solution
ensuite c'est soit de faire appel à un
avocat soin d'écrire au procureur et ça
permet de déposer plainte soi-même wiki
home vous avez une question dont je
recherche activement une avocate ans au
monde
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ici
je ne sais pas si m leur alice movie à
une fréquentation je pense qu'elle est
en vie dans cette montée